I have a morning meditation that I do
um well I wake up now I get my sunlight
I hydrate I use the bathroom I do all
the things that I talk about
um I've started to practice a prayer in
the last year which is new ish for me
which is we could talk about it in the
morning yeah can you talk about it a
little bit sure yeah and I and then I
have a meditation that I do that
actually is where I think through with
the different roles that I play so I
like I start very basic
um I say you know okay I'm an animal
like we are we are like biologically
animals right human
you know I'm a man I'm a scientist I'm a
teacher I'm a friend I'm a brother I'm a
son you know I go through this I have
this list and I think about the
different roles that I have and the
roles that I still want in my life going
forward that I haven't yet fulfilled it
just takes me it's sort of an inventory
of where I've been where I'm at and
where I'm going as they say
um and I don't know why I do it but I
started doing it this last year I think
because
um it helps me understand just how many
different uh contexts I have to exist in
and and remind myself that there's still
more that I haven't done that I'm
excited about So within each of those
contexts there's like things that you
want to kind of accomplish to Define
that yeah and I'm ambitious so I think
you know I'm a brother I have an older
sister and I love her tremendously and I
think I want to be the best brother I
can be to her which means maybe a call
maybe just
um you know we do an annual trip
together for our birthdays our birthdays
are close together we always go to New
York for our birthdays if we've gone for
last three four years like really like
reminding myself of that role not
because I'll forget but because I have
all these other roles I'll get pulled
into I say the first one I'm an animal
because I have to remember that I have a
body that needs care
like any of us I need sleep I need food
I need hydration I need that I'm human
that that the brain of a human is is
marvelously complex but also
um marvelously uh self-defeating at
times and so I've been thinking about
these things in the context of the
different roles and the whole thing
takes about four or five minutes and I
just find it brings me a certain amount
of clarity that then allows me to
ratchet into the day the prayer piece um
yeah I think I've been reluctant to talk
about
um until now
um because I don't believe in pushing
religion on people and
um and I think that
um and I'm not
um it's a highly individual thing and I
do believe that one can be an atheist
and still pray
um or agnostic and still pray but uh for
me it really came about through
understanding that there are certain
aspects of myself
that I just couldn't
resolve on my own and no matter how much
therapy no matter how much and I haven't
done a lot of it but no matter how much
plant medicine or other sorts of
medicine or exercise or
um podcasting or science or friendship
or any of that I was just not going to
resolve and so
um I started this because uh someone
close to me
um said a male friend said you know
prayer is powerful
and I said well how and I said I don't
know how but if you if you can get it
can allow you to Get outside yourself
get let you give up control and at the
same time take control I don't even like
saying take control but the whole notion
is that
again forgive me but there's no other
way to say it the whole notion is that
you know like God works through US
whatever God is to you he he him her
whatever life force nature whatever it
is to you right that it works through us
and so I do a prayer I'll just describe
it where I I ask
um I make an ask to help remove my
defects my Character defects I I pray to
God to help remove my Character defects
so that I can show up
um better in all the roles of my life
and do good work like to which for me is
learning and teaching learning and
teaching and and so you might say well
how is that different than a meditation
well it I'm acknowledging that there is
something that bigger than me bigger
than nature as I understand it that I
cannot understand or control nor do I
want to and I'm just giving over to that
and does that make me less of a
scientist I I sure tell hope not I
certainly know I there's the head of our
neurosciences at Stanford until recently
um I you should talk to him directly
about it Bill Newsom has talked about
his religious life
um for me it's really a way of getting
outside myself and then understanding
how I fit into this bigger picture and
it's and the Character defects part is
real right I'm a human I have defects
like I got a lot of flaws in me like
anybody but
um and trying to
acknowledge them and asking for help in
removing them not magically but through
right action
through my right action
so I do that every morning and um I have
to say that it's helped it's helped a
lot it's helped me be better to myself
be better at other people
um I still make mistakes
um but it's a it's becoming a bigger
bigger part of my life and I never
thought I'd talk like this
um but
I think
it's clear to me that
if we don't
believe in something
again doesn't have to be traditional
standardized religion but if we don't
believe in something bigger than
ourselves we uh at some level will
self-destruct
I really I really think so it's power
and it's powerful in a way that all the
other stuff meditation all the tools is
is not because it's really operating at
a much deeper and bigger level and um
you know if
yeah I think I think that's all I I can
talk about it um mostly because I'm
still working out you know the
scientists in me wants to understand how
it works and I want to understand and
the point is to just go you know there's
some there's you know for lack of a
better language for it there's higher
power than me and what I can control I'm
giving up control on certain things and
somehow that restores a sense of agency
for for right action better action I
think perhaps a part of that is just the
humility that comes with acknowledging
there's something bigger and more
powerful than you and then you can't
control everything yeah it's I mean that
you go through life as a hard driving
person you know forward Center of mass I
remember being that way since I was
little it's like a new LEGOs I'm like
all the Legos I was like on the weekends
you know learning about medieval weapons
and giving lectures about it in class
when I was five or six years old we're
learning about tropical fish and you
know cataloging all of them at the store
and then organizing it and making my you
know my dad drive me or my mom drive me
in some fish store and then spending all
my time there until they throw me out
and all of that but I also remember my
entire life I would secretly pray
when things were good and things weren't
good but mostly when things weren't good
because it's important to pray for me
it's important to pray each morning
regardless but when things
weren't right I couldn't get make sense
of them I would secretly pray but I felt
kind of ashamed of that for whatever
reason and then it was once in college I
distinctly remember I I was having a
hard time with a number of things
um and I took a run
down to Sands beaches UC Santa Barbara
and I remember I just I was like I don't
know if I even have the right to to do
this but I'm just praying I just prayed
for
uh
the ability to be as brutally honest
with myself
and with other people as I possibly
could be about a particular situation I
was in at that time
I mean I I think now it's probably safe
to say I'd gone off to college because
of a high school girlfriend we'd she
essentially she was my family more
frankly more than my biological family
was at a certain stage of life and we'd
reached a point where we were diverging
and it was it was incredibly painful it
was like losing everything I had and I
was like what do I do how do I manage
this do I you know I was ready to quit
and join the Fire Service just to
support us so that we could move forward
and and
um and you know it's just but praying
just saying I can't figure this out on
my own it's sort of like I can't think
of this out on my own and how
frustrating that is no number of friends
could tell me or and inner wisdom
couldn't tell me and eventually led me
to the right answers and she and I are
friendly friends to this day she's
happily married with a child and
um we're on good terms but I think
you know it's
it's a it's a scary thing but it's the
best thing when you
can't control all this and asking for
help I think is also the piece you're
not asking for some magic hand to come
down and take care of it you're asking
for the help to come through you right
so that your body is used to do these
right works right action isn't it
interesting that this secret thing that
you're almost embarrassed by that you
did it as a child is something you oh
man it's another thing you do as you get
older is you realize like those things
are part of you and it's actually a
beautiful thing yeah a lot of the
content of the podcast is you know deep
applicative content and we talk about
everything from you know uh Eating
Disorders to bipolar disorder to
depression you know a lot of different
topics but the tools are the protocols
as we say right the sunlight viewing all
the rest
um you know a lot of that stuff is just
stuff I wish I had known when I was in
graduate school if I'd known to go
outside every once in a while and get
some sunlight not just stay in the lab
I would have you know I might not have
hit like a really tough round of
depression when I was a postdoc and
working twice as hard and you know when
my body would break down or I'd get sick
a lot I don't get sick Much Anymore
occasionally about once every 18 months
to two years I get a you know get
something but
um
you know I used to break my foot
skateboarding all the time I couldn't
understand what's wrong with my body I'm
getting injured I can't do what everyone
else can now I developed more slowly at
a long Arc of puberty
um but I so that was part of it I was
still developing but you know how to get
your body stronger how to build
endurance like no one told me the
information wasn't there so a lot of
what I put out there is the information
that I wish I had had because once I had
it I was like wow like a this stuff
really works B it's grounded in
something real you know some place
sometimes certain Protocols are a
combination of you know animal human and
animal and human studies sometimes
clinical trials sometimes there's some
mechanistic conjecture for some not all
I always make clear which but in the end
like
figuring out how things work so that we
can be happier healthier more productive
suffer less like reduce the suffering of
the world
um and I think that
well I'll just say thank you and um
for asking about the prayer piece
um
again I'm not pushing or even
encouraging it on anyone I've just found
it to be tremendously useful for me